hop là ça fait un mois que l'a pas vu le
décor trois histoires d'horreur
aujourd'hui j'ai la voix un petit peu
granuleuse est ce un problème
on va devoir faire avec cette question
n'a aucun intérêt j'avais adoré les
trois histoires de la dernière fois
parce que les personnes qui étaient
menaçantes
on en apprenait plus sur elle à la fin
de l'histoire on savait qui elle est et
pourquoi elle était là et c'était
vraiment chouette
et devinez quoi aujourd'hui ce sera
aussi le cas elles sont vraiment pas mal
rassurez-vous tout le monde va bien
comme d'habitude je me permettrai pas de
raconter une histoire où la personne de
finit mal à la fin mais encore une fois
ils ont été confrontés à des personnes
dont on n'aimerait pas à croiser le
chemin pop à paul juste avant de passer
aux trois histoires vous savez des fois
je fais des petites recommandations de
films de séries d'horreur et bien
aujourd'hui je pèse dans game puisque
c'est ma première recommandation
sponsorisés octobre
je vais vous parler de la série sème une
série d'horreur dispo sur pran vidéo
l'histoire 2ème se passe en 1953 pendant
la grande migration afro américaine on
parle d'un mouvement qui a conduit 6
millions d'afro américains du sud des
états unis vers le midwest le nord-est
et l'ouest du pays pourquoi parce qu'ils
fuyaient le racisme du sud des états
unis en espérant trouver du travail dans
les grandes villes industrielles
la série met en scène une famille les
emery une famille qui cachent quelques
secrets mais j'aime à rebrousse-poil il
quitte la caroline du nord pour
rejoindre un quartier résidentiel
entièrement blanc de los angeles
vous savez les quartiers typiquement
américain avec les petites maisons
alignées leur jardin ou tout à l'air
parfait
non non tout se passe bien pendant à peu
près 16 secondes à l'issue desquelles on
comprend rapidement que tout quartier
est en fait une énorme bang de harceleur
raciste en plus de ça comme si ça
suffisait pas on comprend rapidement que
la maison des emery est un peu habité
par des présence maléfique par exemple
ce mec ou clairement soirée tu lui
parles pas trop et attention comprend
assez vite que sous leurs airs de
famille parfaite les emery ont vécu un
énorme drame c'est la mère de la famille
qui est à l'origine du déménagement
parce qu'elle a vécu quelque chose
d'extrêmement traumatisant que les
habitants en caroline du nord et no
spoil mais la scène est ignoble
alors est-ce qu'ils vont réussir à
vaincre leurs démons et les connards de
raciste qui les entoure vous saurez en
regardant la série disponible dès
maintenant sur prime vidéo c'est la fin
de cette recommandation hashtag à desk
passons aux trois histoires d'horreur
c'est parti on commence avec la première
histoire celle d'isaac
à l'époque il en coloc avec un mec plus
vieux que lui qui s'appelle françois et
qui est policier dans la coloc isaac
d'or dans le canapé lit du salon et
françois lui dort dans la seule chambre
de l'appartement françois boss la
journée ou soirée isaac boss de chez lui
et tout va bien
illzach il a des petits problèmes de
sommeil et ce soir-là il tape l'insomnie
de sa vie c'est à dire qu'ils dorent
zéro minute une insomnie relou d'un coup
tu regarde à travers la fenêtre et il
fait jour et tu te dis j'ai une
journée taf j'ai dormi zéro minute
comment je vais faire
il part de son appartement pour aller
acheter une boisson énergisante
en rentrant chez lui prêt à boire sa
merveilleuse boissons énergisantes n'est
ce pas il voit que la porte de la
chambre de son colloque est toujours
fermé et c'est bizarre parce que
françois et policiers il devrait déjà
être partie au travail astor l'aï lac en
tire une conclusion évidente françois
est malade il a dû se réveiller dans le
mal avec une nausée ou je sais pas quoi
appeler le travail pour les prévenir et
il s'est endormi bref des trucs qui
arrivent et en ouvrant la porte ils
découvrent que les volets de la chambre
sont fermées et que françois est bel et
bien allongé dans son lit le front qui
dépasse de la couette isaac retombe dans
le salon il sort son pc et il se met à
bosser il est maintenant 14 heures et
françois est toujours pas sorti de sa
chambre depuis ce matin donc il a l'air
d'être vraiment très malade
le temps passe et isaac il est de plus
en plus fatigués puisque je vous
rappelle qu'il n'a pas dormi de la nuit
et donc ils décident de faire une petite
sieste parce qu'ils n'arrivent plus à
bosser à cause de la fatigue
il se rêvait aux alentours de 16 heures
il regarde en direction de la chambre de
françois et la porte est toujours fermée
le temps passe les heures passent il est
maintenant 22 heures isaac est
complètement ko à cause de la nuit
blanche qui vient de passer et ils
décident d'aller prendre des news de
françois mais au moment où il se lève du
canapé pour aller vers la chambre
quelqu'un frappe à la porte d'entrée
isaac s'approche de la porte est arrivé
devant la porte il entend quelqu'un
maître des clés dans la serrure illzach
il est figé devant la porte il comprend
pas il se dit mais attends qui est en
train de rentrer dans l'appart la la
serrure se déverrouille et isaac se
retrouve face à françois l'a évidemment
gros blanc françois regarde isaac en lui
disant bas qu'est ce que tu as fait trop
ça va ça fait deux jours la zac réalise
un truc très relou il ya deux jours
françois lui avait dit qu'il allait
partir en week-end avec des amis sauf
que c'est très rare que françois
prennent des vacances et isaac il est
oublié cette info il prend françois par
le bras il se précipite hors de la
partie et lui dit mec qui est dans son
lit
françois il prend très au sérieux
l'histoire et malgré le fait qu'il ait
pas son arme de service qui fonce dans
la partie il accueillerait sur le palier
il a du mal à réaliser ce qui se passe
mais quand même il prend son téléphone
et il appelle la police
la police nous expliquent qu'ils
arrivent dans 10 minutes et lui demande
de rester sur le palier avec françois
maintenant que de façon ils sont hors de
danger puisqu'ils ont enfermé l'inconnu
dans leur appart mais cette instruction
elle arrive un peu tard puisque françois
il est déjà dans l'appart à ce moment là
du coup après avoir raccroché isa qui se
dit est ce que françois va bien ou est
ce qu'il est en train de se frapper avec
le mec du lit qu'est ce qui se passe là
bas ils rentrent dans l'appartement
il va dans la chambre et là ils
découvrent françois qui vient d'assommer
le mec qui dort avec la canette de
boisson énergisante acheté le matin même
par isaac suite à son insomnie il a le
visage creusé des cernes énorme
il fait crade bref c'est un mec pas beau
à voir et c'est surtout un mec que ni
françois ni zac ne connaissent la police
arrive donc sur les lieux elle rentre
dans la chambre elle tombe sur le mec
assommé par une canette par françois qui
leur explique bon voila il dort dans mon
lit je sais pas qui sépare la canette
quoi sur la tête ils lui mettent les
menottes il embarque tout le monde va
bien il n'y a pas de combats ou quoi le
gars était assommés et bien écoutez
c'était un mec activement recherché par
la police pour vols et agressions
sexuelles
en fait il est rentré dans l'appart
quand isaac est allé acheter sa canette
de boisson énergisante comme ils
pensaient que françois était dans ma
partie
il n'a pas fermé à clé dans la lutte et
c'est à ce moment là que l'inconnu est
venu et s'est immiscé dans le lit de
françois
du coup si vous allez acheter une
canette de boisson énergisante peut-être
vérifier la chambre du colloque avant un
petit coup d'oeil
ça me fait penser à un truc cette
histoire c'est que quand j'étais plus
jeune mon beau père il fermé tout le
temps à clé chez nous la journée et ça
me saoule et de fou puisque moi je
faisais plein de va-et-vient dehors pour
voir des potes des trucs visé mais
pourquoi tu fermes et me disait écoute
le cas on sait jamais tu verras quand tu
raconteras plein d'histoires flippante à
sur youtube dans 10 15 ans tu verras que
j'avais raison et ben écoute jean
françois tu avais raison
je suis ravi de ne pas avoir trouvé un
inconnu dormir dans mon lit grâce à toi
merci sachez que cette première histoire
c'était celle d'un français qui l'a mis
sur le sombre et d'idées histoire
française je vous remets lien s'il y en
a qui veulent raconter des trucs hésitez
pas deuxième histoire cette fois on
retourne aux états unis c'est celle de à
main anna vit dans une petite communauté
rurale dans l'est des états unis s'est
vraiment genre une toute petite ville
elle bosse dans le domaine médical et
donc elle connaît pas mal des forces de
l'ordre les pompiers bref tous les gens
qui bossent dans la ville comme c'est le
cas dans toutes les petites villes tout
le monde se connaît un peu
elle prend le temps précisé que du coup
il ya beaucoup de ragots d'histoire de
commérages tout ce qu'on aime bref
l'histoire s'est passé il ya un an à
l'époque canal célibataire et elle vient
de déménager deux fois de suite à cause
d'un harceleur mais précise que ça c'est
une autre histoire et qu'elle racontera
une autre fois cependant c'est un détail
pertinent pour plusieurs raisons à cause
de ce harceleur elle a acheté un chien
ainsi que des caméras à l'extérieur de
chez elle sa maison elle est dans la
même rue que la caserne des pompiers est
que le poste de police ça veut dire
qu'en cas de problème anin et les
tranquilles et détail important elle
précise que juste à côté de la caserne
des pompiers il ya une sorte de grand
parking sur lequel tous les véhicules du
service public ce gars est bizarrement
sur ce parking là il n'y a pas de caméra
et ça va être un problème ce soir là
c'est la fête nationale donc le quartier
ils organisent tout un tas de petits
événements anna sort son chien il vient
moments paisibles puisque comme tout le
monde et à des fêtes ou chez des voisins
bahia personne dehors il ya aucun bruit
mais elle voit au loin en contrebas gros
pick up blanc traverser la rue salah
folle pas plus que ça jusqu'à ce qu'elle
le voit faire le même chemin en sens
inverse
vingt secondes plus tard et cette fois
il se gare sur le parking et des
véhicules du service public sauf que ce
pick up blanc c'est clairement pas un
véhicule des services publics anna elle
précise que c'est plutôt commun que des
gens viennent généralement la nuit' se
garer sur ce fameux parking et décharger
des trucs et les mettre dans les camions
poubelles la plupart du temps parce que
ces gens ne veulent pas aller jusqu'à la
décharge qui est beaucoup plus loin elle
a donc déjà vu ça plusieurs fois sauf
que généralement les gens qui font ça ce
qu'ils sortent de leurs véhicules cédés
encombrants genre des meubles cassés des
chaises de bureau casser des trucs gros
et chiant ce soir là ce que le chauffeur
récupère à l'arrière de son véhicule
c'est trois grands sacs poubelles noirs
et ils les jettent un par un dans la
trémie du camion poubelle il remonte
dans son pick-up est il par anna elle a
un feeling chou
elle se dit mais attends pourquoi venir
illégalement mettre des ordures dans un
camion poubelle garer si ce que tu y
mets ce sont de simples sacs poubelles
que tu pourrais mettre dans n'importe
quelle poubelle dans la rue c'est
bizarre c'est pas commun du coup ce soir
là pour la première fois elle appelle la
police quelques minutes plus tard un
officier arrive elle le rejoint et lui
explique précisément ce qu'elle a vu
pourquoi elle trouve ça suspect et dans
quelques camions poubelles l'homme à
déposer les sacs poubelles l'agent se
dirige vers le camion poubelle
en arrivant il prend quelques photos des
sacs et puis mes décors et il demanda à
nad rester en retrait
le sac sous là j'en regarde ce qu'il
contient et il devient tout blanc
il fait trois pas en arrière et il dit
merde il ya un corps découpé dans le sac
anaëlle et mega choqué et là évidemment
quand des policiers tombent sur un
cadavre découpé dans les sacs poubelles
c'est pas genre ah ben on remet à demain
on va enquêter merci non le policier il
appelle le shérif le shérif y débarque
en cinq minutes il ya des policiers qui
arrivent toutes les cinq minutes de
partout jusqu'à un moment donné où l'un
des policiers raccompagne anna chez elle
en lui disant bon bah merci de nous
avoir appelé désolée à vous d'avoir
entrevu ça et on vous tient au courant
allez ciao anna cette belle gosse elle a
quand même pris soin de faire une copie
de toutes les images des caméras de
surveillance qu'il ya autour de sa
maison caméra sur lesquelles on voit en
contrebas le parking est donc le pick up
et on entrevoit un peu le chauffeur
descend du pick up est leur envoie tout
ça et puis l apa news pour nos moments
et elle est un peu embêté parce qu'elle
se dit attends il ya un mec qui vient de
déposer un cadavre découpé juste en bas
de chez moi assez chaud et puis quelques
jours plus
le shérif l'appelle pour lui donner des
news et essaie de la rassurer et il lui
explique que l'enquêté est toujours en
cours mais que ce serait apparemment lié
à un règlement de comptes au sein de la
mafia locale mafia dont un à ignorer
totalement l'existence
elle explique que ça l'a quand même
vachement fevad et que depuis elle a
décidé de re déménager dans une zone
cette fois ci un peu moins reculé et qui
ne donne pas sur des zones désaffectée
dans lesquels apparemment des gens
déposent et kadam est ce que c'est bon
pour vous en vrai à na championne
franchement elle a eu du flair elle a vu
ce truc là elle en avait déjà vu plein
déposer des trucs mais là il s'est dit
c'est pas normal cadavres allez hop
j'en rigole mais c'est horrible mec
messieurs dames c'est l'heure de la
troisième histoire celle de mode à
l'époque mode à 18 ans et elle travaille
à la réception de sa résidence
universitaire petit bémol l'ensemble du
bâtiment fonctionne avec un système de
clé magnétique
sauf que le système est obsolète
pourquoi ce obsolètes parce que du coup
quand les piles sont mortes bah tu peux
plus ouvrir la porte avec les clés
magnétiques et ya tout un processus
assez long pour remplacer les piles et
reprogrammé laporte bref un soir vers 1h
du mat un mec aux cheveux longs se rend
à la réception depuis l'intérieur de
l'hôtel et larry face à maud et lui
explique qu'il a oublié sa clé dans la
chambre et lui demande de lui refaire
une allure fait donc une carte
elle lui donne et il remonte dans sa
chambre deux heures plus tard vers 3h du
mat
l'étudiant revient à la réception et
explique un mode qui n'arrivent pas à
accéder à sa chambre d'hôtel mode lui
demande s'il a reperdu saclay il lui dit
d'un enjeu l'est mais la porte ne
souffre pas du coup mode dans sa tête ça
fait eurêka les piles sont mortes fait
chier elle explique donc à sept
étudiants qu'elle va devoir remonter
avec lui et l'échangé qui en a pour un
petit moment l'étudiant lui dis ok pas
de souci lui demande son nom et il lui
donne pas le sien en retour et c'est
qu'on met généralement quand une demande
son prénom à quelqu'un c'est pour donner
le tien juste après ou vice versa et
mode ça la gêne elle dit bizarre elle
arrive devant la chambre de l'étudiant
elle ouvre la porte avec une clé donc
manuellement un truc qui marche sans le
système de pile à la con elle rentre
dans la chambre et pulse mais a accédé
au panneau de contrôle et à faire ce
qu'il faut et elle demande à l'étudiant
de laisser la porte ouverte et
l'étudiant lui dit non
c'est bizarre mais mode ça n'inquiète
pas vraiment à ce moment là puisqu'elle
a déjà changé pas mal de fois les piles
du put un panneau de contrôle est
généralement les étudiants il aime pas
trop laisser grande ouverte la porte de
leur chambre parce qu'ils ont peur que
les autres voient ce cas dans leur
chambre etc bref
et puis l'étudiant la regarde au loin il
lui dit j'ai un blème avec mon lit aussi
il est cassé est ce que tu peux le
réparer ça te plait moldus d'ibadan je
finis déjà le truc de la porte et après
on voit pourtant hélas cet étudiant lui
explique qu apparemment il y aurait une
fuite sous frigo qu'il faudrait qu'elle
aille voir ça aussi et il n'aurait pas
dû lancer plein de problèmes aléatoires
et à chaque fois dans tout c'est blême
la résolution c'est maud qui devrait
s'allonger par terre pour accéder aux
trucs à un moment donné l'étudiant lui
proposent qu'elle enlève ses lunettes
ce qu'est une proposition étrange soyons
honnêtes on a rarement 10 a déjanté show
pourriture et telenet frérot mode lui
répond et lui dit non j'ai besoin de mes
lunettes pour voir si vraiment si je les
ai pas je vois que dalle et c'est là que
l'étudiant change complètement de ton de
manière beaucoup plus calme et beaucoup
plus flippante
il lui dit mode c'est bon tu peux les
enlever
elle reste calme et lui dit écoute non
merci je dois les garder elle explique
que même si le mec lui faisait graver
peur à ce moment là elle veut pas
risquer de le contrarier elle veut pas
provoquer une réaction quelconque elle
veut juste être lisse et sans fuir le
plus vite possible de ce truc peu de
temps après elle ouvre la porte de la
chambre pour accéder aux kits de
réparation de la porte qui se trouve
dans le couloir et quand il fait ça
l'étudiant saute sur la porte et la
ferme et indiana je veux que cette porte
reste fermée et pendant qu'elle est dans
cette position relou l'étudiant lui est
quasiment collé à elle et du toucher les
cheveux
là c'en est trop pour mode elle pousse
le mec elle sort de la chambre
elle lui dit mec tu me touches pas et
l'étudiant qui tient la porte grande
ouverte lui dit non mais c'est bon on
revient et s'il te plaît réparé le lit
parce qu'il ya vraiment un truc qui va
pas et là elle réalise un truc il n'y a
rien dans sa chambre d'étudiant ya pas
de vaisselle dans la cuisine n'y a pas
de rideaux de douche dans la salle de
bain il n'y a pas de gras sur le lit y'a
rien et si y'a rien ça veut juste dire
que c'est pas sa chambre
maud tripote le panneau de contrôle
quelques secondes elle lui dit c'est bon
c'est réparé et elle fonce vers
l'ascenseur arrivé à l'ascenseur elle se
rend compte que l'étudiant n'est plus
dans sa chambre mais qu'il est dans le
couloir et qui la regardent en lui
criant dessus en lui disant et c'est pas
réparer la porte à ce moment la mode
attend l'ascenseur elle se sent vraiment
pas ça eiffel est obligé de le
confronter et elle fait un move de fous
où elle accompagne de nouveau jusqu'à sa
chambre elle ouvre la porte
manuellement avec la clé l'étudiant
rentrer dans sa chambre et puis elle lui
donne la clé en lui disant moi j'ai fait
ce que j'ai pu je n'arrive pas donc
demain j'en vois une équipe
allez bonne nuit elle elle referme la
porte et elle dévale les escaliers de
l'hôtel jusqu'à la réception
elle commence à chercher l'historique de
la chambre dans l'ordinateur et elle se
rend compte que la chambre est censé
être vide y'a pas d'étudiants
actuellement dans section mode elle
appelle donc directement la sécu en leur
disant dégager un blême
venez vite et à peine elle raccroche qui
se pointe le soi-disant étudiants et là
le mec fait un truc trop bizarre et
déchire le coin d'un morceau de papier
qu'ils avaient sur le bureau et de suivi
dessine une fleur pourquoi face à ça
elle est pas touchée elle est tétanisée
et en levant les yeux
ouf les mecs de la sécurité sont là
hélas entame une longue discussion trop
bizarre où il dit aux agents de sécurité
ville a axé sa chambre d'étudiant les
agents titulaires garde et lui disent
mes frères on tue n'est pas étudiant et
ce n'est pas tâche en à l'issue de cette
longue discussion lunaire où le mec est
clairement entrain de mythos les agents
de sécurité le dégage de l'hôtel mais
personne n'appelle pour autant la police
puisqu'il n'a rien fait de combat n'a
blood illégale aux yeux de la loi il a
menacé personne il a agressé personne
c'est juste un mec a voulu secouer
terrain
qui n'est pas le sien mais l'un des
agents de sécurité va quand même faire
un rapport à la police au cas où
et qu'est-ce qu'il a bien fait quelques
semaines plus tard modèle apprend en
fait que le mec qui était là c'est un
mec c'était déjà fait arrêter par la
police pour falsification de papiers
d'identité
parce qu'il avait déjà tenté de se faire
passer pour un étudiant dans des campus
universitaires en gros son truc c'est de
squatter un logement étudiant et de se
faire passer pour un étudiant et de
devenir pote avec les étudiants c'est
beaucoup de fois le mot étudiants et ses
motivations c'était déjà le prix des
logements étudiants qui est beaucoup
moins cher que des logements des
étudiants et surtout se rapprocher des
étudiants te messieurs dames c'est la
fin de ce serait d'horreur j'espère
qu'il vous a plu pendant pas mal de
temps je me disais ça doit être
trop cool cette expérience de campus
universitaire où tout le monde est dans
sa chambre il ya que des jeunes qui sont
là pour étudier et qui fait à trop bien
bah je veux plus voilà vous m'entendez
je ne veux plus bref je retourne lire
plein d'histoires pour vous en raconter
quelques semaines plus tard encore une
fois bonne vacances plein de bonnes
choses gros bisous c'est chaud
[Musique]